hey everybody michael knowles here host
of uh
you know you know the thing you know one
of the highlights
of 2020 it's also one of the low lights
of 2020
but it's been funny at least or the joe
biden
gaffes watching joe biden just
absolutely shove his foot all the way as
far down his mouth that it actually
comes back out his foot
from the gibberish to the corn pop
these i think are the best biden gaffes
of the year be sure to let me know which
biden gaff you think was the best
and which one which ones you think we
can look forward to
in 2021 and corn pop was a bad
dude i just walked out the side door of
saint peter's basilica
after a meeting and getting an
opportunity to shake hands and have a
brief conversation with
pope francis the first people i saw
were a group of nuns who to me epitomize
everything pope francis talked about in
his homily and what he stands for
about generosity to other people about
reaching out
about making it a point to understand
that we are our brother's keeper
and that's what in my experience being
raised as a catholic and educated by the
nuns that's what
those lovely women i'm talking to
symbolize to me so i thought it was a
good omen
when joe biden was vice president his
administration tried to
litigate nuns into the dirt because the
nuns wouldn't provide abortion pills to
people
that's what joe biden did he tried to
force nuns to pay for birth control and
abortion and violate not just
their moral conscience but the faith
that joe biden pretends to hold
basic elements of the faith that the
apostate joe biden pretends to hold
as he supports not just open widespread
abortion
but taxpayer-funded abortion
he signaled that he would do that that
again as president
he's he's overturned his formerly
egregious but somewhat more moderate
stances on abortion now he wants
all taxpayers to pay for it that's why
he was denied the eucharist
because he's in a very clear public
state of grave mortal sin
and shows absolutely no remorse for it
whatsoever the simple fact is
it is not acceptable for any practicing
catholic to vote for joe biden it is not
acceptable
and you are imperiling your soul if you
do it but he's going to try to appeal
anyway still i don't think very many
serious catholics are going to take that
seriously
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true
international depression i'll lead an
effective strategy
to mobilize
i listen to this quote i've probably
listened to it now 50 times
i think at least some of what he's
saying is true
true something international pressure
can we play that again can we go back to
that other truenet
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true international pressure
so there are too many syllables
obviously in there but i think what he's
trying to get at is true
international pressure but i don't think
he's going to mobilize true
international pressure
i don't think that anybody is going to
pay him any heat at all
because his brain is putting i know it's
sort of sad to say that
but the man is past his sell-by date
folks and so when you vote for him
i can't feel too sometimes i say oh i
feel bad for joe i don't feel bad for
joe i don't feel bad for guys who sue
nuns
because they won't pay for abortions i
don't feel bad for that i don't i don't
feel bad for guys
who've lied through their teeth for 50
years in government and who have engaged
in corrupt deals in ukraine and china
apparently i don't feel bad for guys who
may become the president of the united
states i think
we shouldn't feel bad for that guy at
all i think we should feel bad for us if
he gets elected
because that guy's not even going to be
the president that guy is gonna go
he's gonna lie in bed and play tetris
all day and
either kamala harris are more likely
that bureaucracy is going to take over
maybe it was just a gaffe maybe it's
just his childhood stutter
that disappeared for 60 years but then
somehow came back
all of a sudden and we have to pretend
that it's a childhood stutter when it's
obviously not it's obviously
decline joe biden again yesterday
because it was a day that ended in y
on the few days that his handlers allow
him to broadcast
outside of his basement he had another
big error
joe biden was giving his typically
soaring rhetoric
in an interview with a local nbc
affiliate
take a listen to his oratory
what's the president doing look
venezuela's top line message is
president trump's policy is an abject
failure
that's the top-line message for those of
you who are not familiar with
teleprompters
or with with political notes sometimes
you'll see the top line message that's
the point you've got to drive home
but that's not you don't say the top
line message that's the part that you
keep quiet
and keep in your head unless you don't
know what to say you've forgotten how to
conduct politics
you're not really in control of your
rational faculties and you're just
reading off of a teleprompter
which is obviously what joe biden is
doing
he's not able even to form these
sentences and it's funny because now
you know the left always projects so
whatever is true of them they just
throw on to the other political party
yesterday they were trying to suggest
that trump had
a cognitive decline or he had a stroke
or some something crazy like that
regardless of what you think about trump
you might hate him you might
hate his policies you might be a
conservative and hate him because there
are disagreements among conservatives
one thing we're talking about today
you can't say the guy is senile
the guy will get up and give a
three-hour speech without a teleprompter
and he'll keep the audience engaged for
the whole thing in fact he keeps the
audience more engaged with that a
teleprompter than he does with a
teleprompter but certainly he can read a
teleprompter
the same cannot be said of joe biden
whether you like joe biden or you hate
joe biden
the guy is obviously in decline and so
if you elect him
what are you electing you're electing
the democratic party apparatus
which far from a separation of powers is
this liberal establishment connected to
the media connected to the universities
connected to
hollywood connected to big technology
today connected obviously
to the party itself and they are pushing
a radical message
that involves violence in the streets
that involves tearing down
our institutions and our statues
and the great men that those statues
represent there is nothing
conservative about that good afternoon
everyone
welcome to kingswood community center
actually that's the one down i used to
work as a joke
you know where you were anyway it's uh
it's great to be here oh that is
sad that is very sad because he walks up
there
like i don't know i don't know what the
joke would be if that were a joke
that he he just got confused right he's
someplace that i guess it's near where
he used to be and then he says
ah we're here at kingman community
center oh wait a second that's
i'm not i'm not there where am i i don't
i'm just joking
just joking definitely not in cognitive
decline
anyway let's move on with the show so he
forgot where he
was he then forgot where president trump
wasn't
it is not a good idea evidence the fact
that
due rhetorical question i'm not
expecting to answer it do you think the
president all of a sudden decided not to
go to tallahassee
because he no longer he thought it was
the interest of the public
east side or jacksonville i mean
jacksonville florida
so he was referring to the president now
moving the republican national
convention from jacksonville florida
maybe back to charlotte maybe back to
the white house who knows there is
an answer that joe biden gave on a
matter of
uh same-sex marriage redefining marriage
a while ago because joe biden for most
of his career
supported the traditional definition of
marriage and then around 2012 he decided
to flip on this and then he wanted to
pretend
that he's always been super duper gay i
don't know he's been very much in favor
of gay rights and redefining marriage
and all these things
so he's given this answer he's repeated
it a lot on the campaign trail
and something about it just doesn't
sound quite right i saw these
two men in the corner when i was getting
out of the car
both well-dressed men in suits lean up
and kiss one another
and then go their separate ways one went
to the hercules building and one went to
the dupont building
and i turned and looked at my dad just
looked at me said joey it's simple
they love each other it's simple joey
they love each other
what prompted me i let the president
know that
i i did not have to evolve at all
i was and uh my wife
my sister all of us we were way
not ahead but we it was never thought to
be a problem with us
that never happened i can tell you i
would bet the farm
i would bet every dollar to my name that
did not happen
two guys in the 1960s in the middle
of the center of delaware did not kiss
one another
because in those days it was
uh not publicly acceptable to do that
and they wouldn't have done even the
guys might have lived together might
have you know sort of done whatever
wouldn't have happened in public and i
promise you joe biden's dad didn't say
sonny
you see you see this perfectly
choreographed moment so that you can use
on the campaign trail 60 years from now
joey they love each other joe no i bet i
something tells me joe biden's dad who
was born
what in like the late 19th century or
something early 20th century
was not this like open-minded liberal
guy was like god joey you know
this is great and in 2012 you should
come out and
defend gay marriage even though you'll
vigorously oppose it for your entire
career
but then you can remember this moment
joey those guys love each other it
didn't happen and joe biden lies about
these things all the time don't forget
he had to drop out of the 1988
presidential race because he was a liar
he lied he's lied about horrible
personal events he lied about
the driver who got into a car accident
with his wife
this tragedy when his wife died he lied
about that guy
and after the guy died a guy felt so
horrible about it for his whole life and
then after the guy died he maligned him
based on nothing and said
that he was a drunk driver the atlantic
even called joe biden out on this story
so here's what joe biden could say you
could say yeah you know look i'm a
product of my age and i kind of don't
really have any beliefs but i went along
with it and so yeah
i opposed homosexuality for most of my
career and then i was okay with
homosexuality but i
supported uh i opposed redefining
marriage and then around 2012 i changed
my mind because it was more politically
expedient and i supported redefining
marriage and that's my career
and you'd say okay well that's true of a
lot of politicians so that's fine
whatever you know okay no big deal
but instead he's got to lie and say oh
yeah man i was
i was dancing to the village people back
in 1962 at the ymca
like no you weren't joe biden you
weren't doing that and none of that is
credible which is why when he gives
answers on anything forget
you know transiting the kids or or gay
marriage or whatever i mean when he
gives answers on taxes when he gives
answers on anything
you can't believe it because the guy has
no
principles this one i i don't think
there's any chance we're going to figure
it out
but but joe biden is very focused on the
importance of
under barack and me it also holds
polluter i'll call polluters accountable
with the most ambitious environmental
justice agenda ever
okay so there you do get at least the
one word which is polluters he is
he is saying polluters there but there
are all these extra syllables all around
and then everything slurs at the back
end of this
joe biden is obviously exhausted these
incidents have gotten worse by the end
of the campaign than they were at the
beginning now
don't forget it for much of the campaign
joe biden has been hiding in his
basement
so you haven't gotten to see many of
these why did the biden campaign choose
to hide him in his basement they used
coronavirus as an excuse
but that obviously was simply an excuse
because they didn't want these moments
because they have seen him and they
interact with him and they know that the
man is obviously in cognitive decline
and he doesn't have any stamina i get it
campaigns are really exhausting i've
been on a lot of campaigns
and i've been on campaign since i was 19
years old and even when i was 19 years
old i was exhausted doing them because
you're working 20 hours a day for 18
months at a time
so i get it but if you get
tired from doing a modest number of
campaign events like joe biden is doing
how on earth are you going to stand up
to the pressures of being president you
can't do it
it is not possible and he won't
even if and i hope it doesn't happen but
even if he does get elected president
joe biden is not going to be a
particularly hands-on president
other people are going to do the job for
him
and unfortunately the the establishment
that that
he is empowering the groups that he is
empowering are socialists
radicals people who don't want equality
of opportunity
they want equality of outcome they will
go in they will take your money they
will redistribute it
they will institute a new american caste
system
that discriminates on the basis of race
and sex they are already doing that
and they are explicitly promising to do
it
that's what you're going to get with joe
biden
and some people are endorsing them joe
biden on msnbc very friendly tv station
just a few days ago
he's chatting with the anchor there and
he's making a strong point about what a
terrible
trump has done on a certain aspect of
legislation except he can't remember the
name of the legislation and
very sadly the anchor has to just give
him the answer at the end
for example the paycheck protection act
you know one percent of the money's gone
out
one percent one percent of the uh the
that's not the paycheck the the um uh
the uh the bill for a small for major
infrastructure
may seem lenny one percent's gone out
why isn't that lady running for
president that lady obviously has a much
clearer grasp
on the policy issues than joe biden does
he doesn't even he's invading against
this one
law and then turns out oh wait a second
it's he's actually thinking about the
other law
very sad very pathetic nobody is trying
to get him to show up out of the
mainstream media out of the democratic
establishment
the only guy who is trolling biden into
getting back onto the campaign trail
is the master troll in chief president
trump who says that joe biden
has basically given up on life
no no he has he's waved a white flag on
life
he doesn't leave his basement joe
biden's been accusing trump of waving
the white flag of coronavirus
surrendering on coronavirus he said no
i'm not doing that
joe biden's waving a white flag he's
waving a white flag on life because he
knows that if he goes out and he talks
and he says hello to anybody
he's going to screw up so he's hiding in
his basement right after trump says this
what happens joe biden decides to come
out of hiding
i'm i'm not sure that this corruption
stuff
it really matters but biden is hiding
anyway because he doesn't want to have
to answer questions on hunter
he doesn't want to have to answer
questions on
on any of these other people so joe
biden shows up
and he's at a campaign event they've got
a band there and he's going to go give a
speech
you've seen the trump rallies you've
seen what 20 000 people there 30 000
people there
sometimes and then you see the biden
rally
joe biden shows up the band is playing
there were probably
18 people in the room he walks down the
stairs
they're playing midnight train to
georgia which is kind of a depressing
song to be playing during a campaign
right because it's all about a guy who
failed
la was too much for the man and so he's
living the life he's come to know
biden's got his little circles there i
don't even know if it's 18 people
it's not it's not even 18. it's probably
a dozen people
okay a little bit more on the side so
okay 18 people you got probably more
staff there than guests
and he's he's old so it's taking him
forever to walk to the stage
he's trying to run a little bit but
that's awkward
handful of claps
[Music]
he's leaving he is leaving on that
midnight train
i know that the polls say that biden is
way up maybe biden is way up maybe
biden's going to win maybe it's going to
be a blowout for joe biden
but you've got to admit it's kind of
weird that trump gets
tens of thousands of people to show up
to his rallies and joe biden can't get
20 people to show up to his rallies
you got to admit that is kind of weird
and beyond
his inability to remember where we are
joe
biden can't formulate the sentences
that will allow him to either get out of
these gaffes or or even
or even just get a coherent idea apart
that's probably the saddest part of it
right
he's just kind of trailing off and oh
yeah sorry i don't know he's he's not
even finishing his sentences they're
just
sentence fragments he was leaving his
campaign office the other day
one of his campaign staffers had to lead
him out
almost holding his hand she
you can see it's a young staffer and
he's kind of
he's looking in other directions and
she's she's
holding him like it's her grandpa like
you know okay come here grandpa don't
nope don't talk to the reporters
the minute the reporters put a
microphone in front of
his face she says okay thanks guys thank
you thank you bye-bye get in the car joe
come on we can't have you talking to
reporters
joe biden he couldn't seem to string the
thoughts together
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're gonna vote
on
uh uh barrett
i think
that is so embarrassing
it's embarrassing for joe it's
embarrassing for the campaign
senator tell us about amy barrett okay
well here's the deal the thing about it
is
uh they're gonna vote today or was it
yesterday or they're gonna uh
uh who and i actually i don't even wanna
make fun of him for it anybody who's had
aged friends or relatives knows this
happens
you know it's a senior moment except
with joey has senior moments all of the
time
don't begrudge him that you know it's
going to happen to all of us probably
someday if we live that long
but it doesn't mean that you should be
president while you're having those
issues
if you cannot give an opinion on the
supreme court confirmation that
just happened you should not be
president you don't have the stamina
to do it and his campaign staff knows it
we've been seeing this for months and
months in the mainstream media are
denying it
where joe will start trying to talk to
the press and he'll start rambling
and they will take him by the arm and
lead him away
come here come here old grandpa so come
here come here old joe
you know let's go we're gonna again if
if joe were just their grandpa perfectly
fine a lovely interaction but he's not
he's trying to be president
oh barrett the today is sort of okay bye
and just leads them away and the press
won't ask a question about it
because the press are campaign
operatives for
for biden now some of the biden gaffes
have been
a little bit funnier maybe they're
freudian slips i don't know
just yesterday joe biden was talking
about uh
about his wife and then kamala harris
and kamala's wife
but my wife jill as you know and doug
imhoff uh
commonly's wife are there common will be
back later this week i think on friday
that may have been a freudian slip which
is obviously where you say one thing but
me and your mother
so joe talks about commonly wife he
meant to say her husband i guess
those issues i know it's
counterintuitive but i think those
issues are going to matter much more
they are trying to go back and gin up
this coronavirus idea
well joe biden has a scary number for
you he is under the impression
that coronavirus has hit 120 million
people already worldwide
i just got off the phone this morning
with uh dr vivek murthy
and uh he and uh and others who
he was a former surgeon general and a
number of experts who
work right have a meeting uh hour and a
half telephone conference with them
zoom conference uh once a week i mean
four times a week
and that's why we have a major
multi-billion dollar investment in
mental health
what people drastically underestimate is
the impact
on the mental health of people who now
everything is complicated not only
is the healthcare piece but people don't
have a job people don't have anywhere to
go they don't know what they're going to
do
and a lot of people you have
unnecessarily now we have
over 120 million dead from covet
over 100 i mean 120 million dead you
know it's funny i actually have to
correct myself the first time i heard
that clip i thought he was saying there
were 120 million cases
worldwide which obviously is not true no
what he said is even crazier he's saying
there's 120 million dead and it seems
he's implying in america which is a
country
of 330 million people that's a lot huh
that's
actually though the number is uh not
anywhere close to that
it's uh multiple orders of magnitude
lower than that
[Music]
[Music]
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video